bonjour pascal irissou merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur arte france
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter la
sortie de pierre moscovici le p r de
flamanville traduction réacteur
pressurisé européen
est ce qu'il va voir le jour un jour ou
jamais alors j'ai lu le rapport de la
cour des compte 140 pages qui sont une
analyse remarquable de la filière rpr en
france elle souligne cette analyse la
dérive des coûts en effet multiplié par
3,3 vous l'avais dit en introduction à
12,4 milliards auxquels il faut rajouter
les coûts complémentaires c'est à dire
les frais financiers estimés par la cour
des comptes à 6,7 milliards d'euros donc
au total un coût de 19 milliards d'euros
au lieu des 3,5 anticipé au début est
d'ailleurs la cour souligne le fait que
l'anticipation des coûts a été mal
conduite
dès le début de l'opération il faut
aussi souligner la dérive delà du délai
de mise en service
il est il a été multiplié par 3,5 à
l'origine dans la cour des comptes
souligne qu'il devait être de 54 mois et
il est estimé actuellement à 181 7 mois
la cour des comptes ne mais en revanche
aucun doute sur la mise en service de ce
réacteur par conséquent je ne peux pas
m'opposer aux conclusions de la cour des
comptes met donc du coup il va être mis
en service cette paire nouvelle
génération il devait être mis en service
en 2012 il se repère aux opérationnels
par avant 2023
quelles conséquences économiques
financières pour edf et pour la
production électronucléaire française de
manière générale alors la production
électronucléaire française quel poids
quel poids a t-elle dans la consommation
énergétique française
je rappelle que l'électricité représente
40 % la consommation énergie énergétique
de la france et que 75% de cette
électricité provient de la filière
électronucléaire filière
électronucléaire d'ailleurs qui a vu le
jour sous la présidence du conseil sous
la quatrième république du président pi
d'air en 1952 et c'est félix gaillard
qui a lancé la le plan pluriannuel
d'énergie nucléaire donc ses études
filière qui a été mise été pensé dès la
quatrième république
les conséquences sont très importants
sur des conséquences évidemment direct
sur le financement d'edf je rappelle que
edf l'état et participe à hauteur de 84
% au capital d'edf que framatome suite
au démantèlement d'areva est maintenant
une filiale d'edf et areva et sa
également aider dans leurs beats d'edf
et areva et sa est en charge de
finaliser le dossier de le pr2 finlande
qui lui aussi a vu son délai x par au
moins cinq puisque à l'origine
areva avait construit avaient commencé à
construire le père en finlande en 2004
pour un prix de vente de 3 milliards
d'euros il ya une dérive des coûts il
est maintenant neuf milliards d'euros et
le délai de mise en service
estimé à 2009 au début et maintenant
devrait être de 2021 donc il ya des
réponses économiques par rapport à tous
ces retards et toutes ces dérives
budgétaires séquence économique
elles sont elles sont de deux ordres
d'une part c'est ce que je rappelais le
poids de l'état dans la filière edf et
edf est dans une situation financière
qui mérite d'être d'être revus de
manière très très précises par l'état
actionnaire
je le rappelle à hauteur de 84% et de
manière générale également c'est la
filière edf qui est d'un filière ppr qui
est qui est mise en cause dans sa dans
son activité d'exportation car vous
savez qu'il y a deux pères qui sont en
ce moment en construction en angleterre
à une révolte qui lie à 6 e p r qui sont
prévus pour être construits en inde et
qu' il y a également deux ep air qui
sont qui sont actuellement en service à
taishan taishan achète deux en chine
par conséquent c'est à la fois une
conséquence directe sur les finances
d'edf et d'areva et d'ailleurs c'est
très bien marquer est il souligné dans
le rapport de la cour des comptes
puisque la cour des comptes souligne le
fait que edf à porter
un préjudice certain sur les défauts de
construction de l'epr de flamanville
mais qu'en même temps il ne peut pas
attaquer areva et ça car si areva et sa
est attaqué par edf areva et ça risque
de ne pas terminer le père de finlande
par conséquent on est dans une situation
où il ya des coûts directs vous avez
raison dans votre question mais aussi
des coûts indirects qui seront liées au
prestige de et à la capacité
d'exportation de la filière de pm
française
merci pascal hays reste d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur d'économie à
l'université américaine de new haven